- Literally rooting for a snow day
was like the most
important thing in my life
at one point.
(laughs)
Like when AccuWeather was wrong,
and I had to go to school,
when they promised me nine inches
and I was gonna be out
- That's hilarious.
- Was devastating.
♪ We can't rewind ♪
♪ Don't waste your time ♪
♪ And we'll find ♪
- [Gary] Hi.
- Hi, Janet.
- Janet, so nice to meet you.
- I love this office.
- Thank you, brother.
Why's my light not working?
Oh.
I saw something.
What's that?
Oh shit, I won.
Can I have a green tea?
- This makes me upset.
- You love that.
- Yeah I love that,
but that makes me upset.
- Well, it's only in the lead.
They'll only in the lead.
- In the lead, got it.
- See what I wrote.
It's in the lead.
- Coffee, water, tea?
- [Janet] I'm so good.
- Your skirt's so cool.
(crosstalk)
How you guys doin'?
- Really good!
We're happy to be here.
- What's that?
Just a green tea would be amazing.
(crosstalk, laughs)
I'm super chachka'ed out
I love this shit.
- But I love this
era of chachkied out,
you know what I mean?
- How old are you?
- I'm 31.
- Yeah it all comes down,
it's just the shit that
you got excited about that
brings back memories, right?
It's why people get pumped
when they see you, right?
They think about a time
- Yeah, yep, yep yep.
- That's what it is.
And by the way, think about
what that time usually means to somebody.
Simple as shit
(laughs)
Shit that you thought
was terribly important
you wish could be your headaches now.
- [Janet] Eating bowls of cereal.
- We were at dinner with this guy named
Bob Gurr
- Bob Gurr
- Who created
the monorail for Disneyland,
he designed all these
- An engineer.
- Yeah he's an engineer,
he was one of the original
Imagineers for Disneyland.
- Cool.
- So he's 80-some years old
and he's got all these crazy stories.
But, he was explaining,
we were talking and we kind of
landed on that of like,
why is it different for
when a fan comes up to us as opposed to
oh yeah, you're on that
- Big hit.
- One show on that one thing
- It's the moment in their lives.
- Because the first time they rode
the front of the Monorail when
they were eight years old,
they have that memory for
the rest of their lives.
So when they see Bob, they're like,
they tie him to that memory.
You know, that simple time of
when it was just
happy go lucky
- So cool.
100 percent.
It's even like,
there's certain songs that I hear
that I like 'cause I know like
they were songs when I liked a girl
you know what I mean?
- Memories.
- Or smells
- Smell is the one that gets you.
That's the one that's
closest tied to memory.
- Well, smell's really tricky 'cause
people manipulate it pretty hard.
Department stores and casinos and
that's where they really get you!
You know?
- [Janet] What do they
pump out that smell like
Merry Christmastime, is it like
- Pumpkin spice, but they do that at
Disneyland too, they pump all the
- Cinnamon's like the big one.
Cinnamon cookies is a big
- [Janet] Gingerbread.
- Well I started acting when I was like
five years old.
- Right, so you didn't even know.
- So it was sort of
(voice on building speakers)
- Perfect, please disregard.
Keep going.
Five years old.
(laughs)
So yeah, so I started acting
when I was really young.
- Right, so you had no fuckin' say.
You didn't have love yet.
- No, I mean
- Your parents wanted you to act?
Or you wanted to act?
- It was a combination.
- Were they like, hey you wanna act?
And you're like, yeah!
(laughs)
I mean you're five.
- [Drake] Yeah, but it was more of
I was obsessed with old, classic
- Oh so you were into it.
- [Drake] Movies and TV
- And where were you living?
- That's why I loved
all this kind of stuff.
I grew up, if you come to my house,
my house looks like Disneyland.
There's just stuff all over the walls
and memorabilia and toys and
it's very colorful and
I grew up on Martin Lewis and
Abbott and Costello and all these great
great comedy teams and Marx Brothers
and all that, Elvis.
And so at a young age, my dad would just
see me kind of trying to
- Do shit.
(laughs)
- Totally.
- Sound like Jerry Lewis
and follow, do this stuff
'cause he originally, he loves baseball.
So he's putting me on little league teams
- Right.
- And I'm,
I'm like, I don't,
- Yeah.
- I like playing baseball,
it's fun.
- You're like doing Who's On First? Skits
- Yeah
(laughs, crosstalk)
- Who's on first?
(laughs)
Making the kids in the dugout laugh
- Laugh.
- Instead of
- Your dad's like, keep your eye on the
fuckin' ball!
(laughs)
- Exactly.
And then he realized, he's like, man
- Good for your dad.
That's a good job by him.
Jersey, right?
- Huh?
- Like in Jersey, where was this?
- No I was in Cali.
- In Cali, got it.
- Well I was in Orange County at the time.
So, yeah,
so he just figured
my kid doesn't want to play baseball,
he wants to be doing something that's
in entertainment.
And so we didn't have any idea,
we had no background, we
didn't know what we were doing.
And then he,
I think he just kind of opened up
OC Weekly and was like,
oh, talent agent.
You know?
Like, old movie
- Yeah.
- And we come in and it's like
(sings game show style music)
you got all the kids lined up and
they're like, 'next'.
And that was just kind of the
- That's cool.
- And then I started doing
commercials and all that.
- Did you freak when you first
saw yourself in a commercial?
- Yeah, as it should.
- It was like, crazy.
I had a kid I went to high school with
that was the face of Nintendo Cereal.
- Oh no way.
- It was the best,
we still think it's the best thing.
It was the best!
- Yeah.
- That's all we
literally first day of high school,
there's like, kid who's the Nintendo
(laughs)
it was that big!
- Yeah I mean, going to school
that's how
- You've done a lot of cereal.
- I was doing,
name a candy, I did the
- You were in it.
- Yeah, I mean I've been
doing it from five to
- You dominated commercials.
- Oh yeah, because he was a little
freckled, red headed kid.
So like, commercial wise, it's like
- The most left field?
I don't know if there's something that was
so wacked-out left field but
I mean, I did the
'the taste you can see',
all the classic ones that you remember.
I've done the Cinnamon Toast Crunch,
Gushers, the
you remember the Gushers commercial
- Yes.
- Where the kid's head
- You were there?
(crosstalk)
- Yeah.
I was one of the
- Did your commercials used to run against
your own show?
- Sometimes.
(laughs)
Sometimes my commercials would run,
because I had multiple commercials
running at the same time.
- That's cool.
- So it'd be like me playing Game Boy
and the next thing would be
me like, "Taco Bell!"
That's so cool.
- Awesome.
- So anyway,
fast forward and then
- How long did that show run?
The one that
- Drake and Josh?
We did, well,
that's an interesting, that's interesting.
We did four seasons.
But we only did 56 episodes.
And it sort of just kind of
became The Honeymooners.
How The Honeymooners did like 33 episodes,
and it just
- Is that all The Honeymooners did?
- Isn't that crazy?
- That's insane!
- And that's what people say when I say
Drake and Josh,
because people imagine
- You're like blown away right now?
- I thought it was a 10 year run.
- You're blown away, D-Rock?
- Yeah it's not.
- People think that
- I think Saved By The
Bell feels like that to me.
- Saved By The Bell was short.
- Yeah.
- Saved By The Bell
was only like 80 episodes.
- Yeah.
Because I feel like I know them all.
(laughs)
- Right.
- I was shocked,
'cause we went to Saved
By the Max the other day,
and I was just
- Pop up in L.A.
- I was getting interested in
re-upping the nostalgia.
- Yep, yep.
- Re-watching episodes.
- Yeah, re-watching the seasons and
I was like, man, I could have sworn!
- Everyone's going to
Saved By The Max, right?
- It's really fun, yeah!
It was fun.
It was really cute.
- College Years only had one season.
- Yeah I know The College
Years only had one season.
- That blows my mind!
I feel like, I've been watching
- I was so obsessed with Kelly Kapowski.
- I mean, how could you not?
- So obsessed with her.
- Yeah, it's crazy but anyway
- So you did that, four years
- 56 episodes.
- And then what happened?
- And then for some reason it just like
- And what happened,
did you start getting into music?
- Mostly drugs and alcohol, no.
No, yeah started playing music a lot and
well I started playing music early.
Like about 10 years old.
- While you were in it.
- Yeah, so I always had
a passion for music.
Started playing drums when I was like
little kid, you know.
- In the basement.
- Yeah exactly.
And then,
didn't want to be in the back of the van.
I wanted to write songs,
I couldn't write on drums,
I had to find other musicians
if I wanted to play music.
You know, so
I was like, screw that,
I want to play guitar.
I had to learn,
fortunately I booked a movie
with Roger Daltrey and Denny Laine
and Carmine Appice and
all these rock legends.
- They really put you on.
- I had to learn to play
guitar for the movie.
So they gave me,
I had to be able to play guitar.
So they gave me this amazing guitar coach.
And so we just serendipitously happened
boom, here you wanted to play guitar?
Here, you can hang out with Roger Daltrey
- Fuckin' crazy.
- It's nuts.
- Two months and
learned everything about
being on the road with The Who and
- Stupid.
- Crazy stories with
Keith Moon and he'd come in the studio,
pick up the guitar and show me stuff.
He was really, really rad.
And then I got to
actually go in the studio
and record with him because
we were doing songs for the movie.
So, at the very beginning of me
starting to play guitar, I'm already
immersed in this crazy
- So cool.
- And then
started writing songs and
putting little bands together
and everything like that.
I booked a show called The Amanda Show
which was basically the
Carol Burnett Show for kids.
And that was Amanda Bines
from All That.
- I remember.
This is not a joke, this is not a joke.
I've seen most of Amanda Bines' movies.
- They're amazing.
- I genuinely, genuinely like
eight to 15 year old girl movies.
- She was great.
- I can agree.
- Yeah, I mean, she was
- The one where she was
like the soccer girl.
- She's The Man, such a good movie.
Such a good movie!
- She's The Man is a fucking
- Channing Tatum,
such a good movie.
- You know what?
I'm tweeting that right now.
She's The Man is an
all time classic movie.
(laughs)
- It really is!
- I'm excited to see
what's about to happen.
I'm about to lose so many followers.
She's The Man
- Actually, you're gonna
notice it's gonna be the opposite.
You're gonna get
- Yeah.
- The tampons
- The Olsen Twins' movies, yeah.
- Billboard Dad.
- Billboard Dad!
- My friend was the
- So good!
- Boyfriend or love
interest from that movie.
- I like the one where
they go to Australia.
Or Atlantis.
- Yep, they were all so good.
- Very good.
Yeah but Amanda Bines is,
she was my favorite.
- You loved her?
- Yeah.
Still
- Yeah, I mean she was amazing.
I got onto that show
which was sketch comedy.
Which I loved, it was like,
it's what I grew up on.
I wanted to be Jerry Lewis
and do sketches and all this stuff.
- You always wanted to be on SNL?
- Yeah, exactly.
So I got to do that,
and then at the same
time I was making music
and the second season of Amanda Show,
they brought on an actor named Josh Peck.
- Mmhmm.
- This really funny, amazing kid
and we were, I was already
a staple on the show,
and he was sort of the newcomer.
So he would,
Amanda and I would do stuff together
and he would be the kid that comes in
and asks for something.
And then we make
everything funny, you know?
But, we started to really gel and just
something, they started to see off camera,
these things happen so they started
putting us in sketches more
together where we worked off each other
and we more becoming the
Tim Conway, Harvey
and becoming sort of
an Abbott and Costello.
And so they spun us off from that show
onto Drake and Josh.
- Drake and Josh.
- That's how it happened.
- Yeah, and so we were just
spun off onto that.
And then, the music on the show,
the way I was able to incorporate
all of my own music was that
Dan Schneider, the executive producer
was just a big fan of the music.
And he'd heard it on the Amanda Show
and all during while
we were shooting that.
And then he was like,
do you want to have him play music?
Do you want your character to
have music incorporated?
Do you want to keep that separate?
What do you want to do?
And I'm like, no!
At the time I'm like, no,
I wanted to be a guitar player.
- Yeah.
- I want to be
a rock n' roll guy
- Yeah of course
- Good music, and yeah,
incorporate the music.
This is actually a cool story.
So I get that phone call
on a Friday and he goes
okay.
Think about it over the weekend.
I want to meet with you on Monday
and we're gonna talk about how
whether or not you even want
to incorporate your music
and if you do, how much?
Do you want to have your own music?
Do you want us to write
songs for the character?
How do we want to approach this?
So I said, okay cool.
So that day I called my
and this was probably like
15 at this point.
Yeah, I'm like 15 at this point.
And so I called my buddy and I go,
hey man, I have this meeting on Monday
about the music, and this
is who I write music with.
Let's get together and try to write a
theme song for the show.
- That's cool.
- And I'm thinking, yeah right,
like we'll ever get it but let's just
why not try it?
- It'd be good to show him.
- And I got a great relationship with Dan,
so I have no fear of him going
- It's shit, or it's great, or yeah
- I don't have any fear
of him saying that.
I'll be like, okay cool.
Let's still get lunch.
So, we went,
I went on that Saturday, I went in and
we were trying to think of all the theme,
♪ Days go by ♪
Different Strokes, all these stupid
theme songs and nothing was coming
and we were just sitting there and just
brain dead for 12 hours, you know?
So I said, screw this, let's just try and
write a song so we don't waste the day.
So then we start writing a song
and it's a pretty cool song,
kinda Elvis Costello
vibe, rock n' roll vibe
and I'm like, this is cool.
Wait a minute,
what does a theme song even sound like?
You're trying to sound like a theme song.
Let's just write a good song.
And make the lyrics sort of go along with
- The themes of the show.
- The themes of the
show, which is basically
these two guys who are
complete polar opposites.
Their parents get married,
and now they have to live
together in the same room.
And they hate each other,
(laughs)
but at the end of the day,
they need each other, they love each other
- Sure.
- It's Bosom Buddies or
it's Perfect Strangers
- Perfect Strangers was the best
- Exactly.
So that's the chemistry,
so we're like, let's
just write a song about
that.
And it became, I never
thought it'd be so simple,
but I found a way, I found a way.
If you open up your mind
it's gonna take some time.
Over your shoulder, I'll always be
picking you up when you're down.
So it's like this very friend like,
hey I got you, brother.
And we recorded a little one minute demo.
I went to
Dan on Monday, and I'm saying,
boombox anywhere?
Actually, funny we talk
about Amanda Bines.
He was working on What I
Like About You at the time.
Amanda's show.
So I was over at the WB a lot,
and we were on our stage and
we found a little boombox
in the prop department
and plugged it in.
He's like, ah man,
can I just listen to it without you here?
I don't know, what am I,
supposed to tap my foot,
snap my fingers?
- Yeah, sure sure.
- This is awkward.
No, dude, if you don't
like it, you don't like it.
We like the same kind of music.
I trust your opinion,
if you don't like it,
then you go with whatever else.
Doesn't ruin my day, whatever.
So he's like, alright.
Presses play, and the one minute
demo version of Found Away goes by
and he just stands up, unplugs it
and walks out of the room
and starts walking over,
"guys, everybody wanna" to everyone
that's working on the stage, he goes,
"you wanna hear the theme
song to my new show?"
He plugs it in onstage
and starts playing it to everybody
- Such a cool moment.
- So cool.
- Sick!
And then,
he just looks at me and he's like,
alright, I just have to
convince Nickelodeon, but
that's our theme song.
What's it called?
Found A Way?
Alright, yeah, that's our theme song.
- So cool.
- So I, of course, 15 year old me
I'm like, what the?
Are you kidding me?
I was expecting,
tap my foot, snap my finger,
hey kid, get outta here.
(laughs)
And it just
- So cool.
- Turned out, yeah
and I got to call my buddy and I was like,
yo, bro, we just got a theme song.
We booked it!
- And then it was a smash hit show.
- Yeah!
And then the show took off and now,
it's crazy, I go to countries
all over the world
where they don't even speak
the language, you know?
- They sing
- Oh!
- You start off with
(sings guitar notes)
they're just,
- So cool.
- The phones are out, everyone knows
every lyric to it.
And it's like we were
talking about it earlier,
it brings them back.
(snaps)
- 100 percent.
- Immediately to that moment,
like you were saying
- Sitting on the couch, simple day.
All you're worried about was like
hoping for a snow day.
- Yeah for me,
when I hear I Get Knocked
Down by Chumbawumba
or something
- Literally, literally
rooting for a snow day was
like the most important thing
in my life at one point.
(laughs)
When AccuWeather was wrong,
and I had to go to school,
when they promised me nine inches
and I was gonna be out
- That's hilarious.
- Was devastating!
You didn't have that in the OC.
- Never got to experience a snow day.
- I grew up in Florida, so
- You warm weather kids,
you fuckin' missed out.
(laughs)
There's nothing like having a test
that you're not prepared for
get snowed out.
(laughs)
- Well, I've had hurricane days.
- Okay, okay.
- Or a tornado day
- Yeah but the problem
with that is people were dead and shit
- Yeah.
- You can't be like, yeah
with me it was like, I missed Science
'cause the snow.
You're like, I missed
Science, 83 are dead.
(laughs)
- True.
- All I got was, oh it's sprinkling,
we're gonna watch a movie
in the auditorium today.
- Right, rain really fucked with you guys.
Rain fucks with L.A.
- It does, people forget how to drive.
- If it sprinkles, you can't drive.
- People literally forget how to drive.
- Florida and it's torrential downpours
and everyone's just
like, get out of the way!
- Yeah, L.A.'s different like that.
- Yeah so I think that
- But yeah so anyway that brings
into the present of now of cutting records
and touring
- Making music
- Focusing on music,
I made a couple movies last year
that came out this year, but
just like when you
yourself so thin it's like
- You feel like you're gravitating
more and more every day to music?
- Yeah, and you can only get so
- The other thing with when I think about
music and acting is
there's something very
evergreen about acting.
Like, if I'm you, knowing your narrative,
especially with having
the win under your belt
of acting,
you can act in 40 years.
- Yeah.
- We say that all the time.
- It feels like music,
to me it would be harder pressed for me
to believe in 40 years
you make that album.
- Yeah.
- Or that song.
It's possible.
It just feels more practical to me
plus you always care about
the thing you don't have.
If you had two hits,
it's the same old thing.
Fuckin' Justin Timberlake wants to win
an Academy Award.
- Right.
- You know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- What you have, the whole
I talk a lot about
entrepreneurship nowadays
and I'm always like,
man it's so crazy.
Athletes used to want to
be rockstars and rappers,
rappers, rockstars used
to want to be athletes
and now everybody wants
to be an entrepreneur.
You just always want what you don't have.
- Yeah.
- It's just human nature.
Especially if you care
about multiple things.
- Mmhmm.
- I love sports.
I gave up on the Rangers and the Yankees
the second they won!
It's all Knicks and Jets now.
It's not like they did anything other than
win a fucking Championship!
- Yeah.
- You know?
It's just the way humans are wired.
- Yeah.
- Especially if you're competitive.
- And it's also
- How do you categorize your music?
I can't wait to go listen now.
- Pop, pop rock
- Pop.
- Well, every album has
been a little different.
- Yeah but I
- Are you signed with somebody?
- No, just myself.
- Love that.
- We're doin' it all ourselves.
- I can control it.
- What can I help with?
What are we,
when you were thinking about this meeting.
- Yeah, it's sort of just kind of
so basically
- How did we get here?
- Okay.
So,
and that's basically what
I was getting into here is
we have more control now with the music.
You're trying to get
acting it's like you're waiting around
for someone to hire you.
- 100 percent.
- With the music
- Waiting for the
phone to ring,
it's bullshit.
- With the music
we can take control and
release records when we want,
make records when we want.
Go tour when we want
- Make videos
- Play where we want and not use
agents, managers, labels, any of that
and just basically
do it ourselves.
So, we're kind of in that,
I'm basically in that position where
for the first time,
I've been on labels, I've been signed,
I've released records every way that
you could think of,
except now I'm doing it by myself,
independent and
- Control the masters.
- Yeah
- Have all the upside
- Be an entrepreneur,
in a sense I'm finding myself
whoa I went from being
an artist on a label
to now I'm like running a business
- AKA you've got to do the marketing
and the distribution,
you gotta think about everything.
- We gotta think about everything
- You gotta get up at 3
o'clock in the morning.
- Do you like that?
- Yeah I love it.
- Yeah, it's great.
- And I love that
- Feels like you can
die on your own sword.
- I'm a creative person,
so I love being able to
- I think I'm super,
I think marketing is so fuckin' creative.
I think people don't
think about it the way
they think about painting
or acting or music.
But like,
the way I think about making
people care about something
feels like super art.
- Absolutely.
- What drew me to
I think I saw you with
my buddy Tee Grizzley.
And then I saw
who was this guy, what's going on here?
And I just started
following you and started
you were just,
everything you were
saying, I'm like, exactly.
- Yeah, that's right!
(laughs)
- Yes.
- So, about two years ago maybe,
I had this whole turn
where I was like, dude,
if I'm not getting up
before everybody else
and getting up, if I'm not doing what
everybody else isn't doing,
then I'm just gonna be like everybody else
and everybody's sitting there going,
oh why didn't it work?
Dude,
and then when you start doing it,
you start getting up, butt crack of dawn,
four in the morning, going to gym,
going doing this and
going to the gym again
and working on everything you're doing,
trying to kill it, you know?
You start to realize when everyone's like,
oh it doesn't work,
you're like, dude, you didn't
get up 'til 10 o'clock.
You didn't start your day 'til noon!
- I'm sitting here laughing
because it's the biggest single thing
that affected them.
You thought you worked hard.
- Yeah, that's the thing!
I mean I see people on Instagram
and they're like, this is
what hard work looks like.
And, it's 11:30 and they look like they
just woke up and they're doing something
on the computer or something.
Or they're editing a
video and you're like,
dude,
you should be,
it's 11:30,
that's like dinner time.
You should be already
boom boom boom boom boom.
So anyway, so,
- Are those the orange sneakers I gave up?
- Yep.
- Fuck they're pretty fresh.
I'm like, why they give the,
I'm looking at them, like,
why did I give those up?
- I noticed when he walked down
- I'm reading the Phil
Knight book right now
it's so sick.
- Me too.
- It's so funny,
that book is like two years old and
- Is it?
- Yeah, I think it's a good 18
it's minimumly 18 months old.
- Oh man.
- It's been brought up
like four times this week.
It's funny how things are in the air.
- It's weird how that works,
the universe does work that way.
- Got it, so that's how
it hit the radar and more importantly
as you did your homework, you're like,
wait a minute, this guy really
or potentially understands
the marketing of
getting people to pay attention to music.
- Exactly, yeah.
And so, it sort of seemed like
he would be somebody that I
doing this on our own
- So ready?
Ready?
It's really simple, it's distribution.
When fuckin',
when the internet's young and
there's 40 fuckin' channels
and you have a hit show on Nickelodeon,
everybody knows who you are.
In today's world, it's
fuckin' so fragmented.
Everything's fragmented.
So it's about figuring out
how to get your music consumed
at all costs.
Now, Soundcloud and Spotify
are fuckin' incredible
because that's the infrastructure
and Apple Music,
that's the infrastructure of
where people naturally go.
I think the white space
is where people don't go.
I think the white space is theme songs.
I think the white space
is Twitch stars playing
with your music in the background.
To me, I just think that
wherever there's attention,
you need to try to figure out
how to get music.
I think that somebody right now
is running marketing.
I think somebody right now is running
retail store operations
at Sephora, who grew up as
you being their biggest crush,
'cause she's 29
and thinks you're the fucking coolest.
And if you figured out
how to get to Sephora,
they would play your fuckin' music
in every Sephora store,
19 times a day on loop.
And somebody's like, what's that hook?
To me, it's how do you penetrate culture?
How does your hook play
on meme pages on Insta,
on people's vlogs,
how does D-Rock use it in a vlog?
- Delta playlist
- That's exactly right.
- Delta airplane, it's like,
you click library, it's like
why wouldn't we be there?
- But here's the thing.
I'm dying to know how many
people actually listen to it.
In a world of an iPhone and all of us
want to listen to our own shit.
What's up, brother?
You know what I mean?
I'm with you, and I'm
not against it at all.
What scares the fuck out of me is
one 18 second snippet in
a fuckin' Paul Brother
vlog one time is gonna
get to a lot of ears.
- Yeah.
- Mmhmm.
- So, to me,
whether it's the theme
songs of video games
while you're making your Dynasty team,
whether it's Twitch players which I think
are absolutely gonna grow at scales that
were especially for pop audiences,
whether it's Dylan's candy bar
is playing it in the stores,
whether it's
it's just fuckin' full penetration.
'Cause you're always one,
you know what's amazing about music?
It's kind of like making videos.
You're one fuckin' at bat away.
It blows my face off that you can
write and record 813 songs,
be 67, record one little fuckin' thing,
randomly on some stupid shit,
like you didn't give it
anywhere close to the thought you did
about 80 other percent of your songs,
and that's the one.
- Yeah.
- I always think,
so, a lot of people when they watch this
will say,
you always say the same advice to
when the rappers come
and hang out with you,
you're always giving the same advice.
I'm like, yeah.
It's what I think is the right thing.
It's like a play in sports.
If they don't stop it, keep running it
and then you win.
To me, it blows my mind
that people were signed to
fuckin' Arista Records and
this has happened hundreds of times
what I'm about to tell you.
Fake scenario.
Artist, manager, label
sitting in a room, 1987.
17 songs for the album,
and they decide to not use the 18th song
and use this other song,
and that 18th song was the fuckin' song.
- Mmhmm.
- That has happened hundreds of times.
The fact that you don't
have to worry about that,
and you can just do little
four pack music albums
- Yes.
- One offs, fuckin',
this is the greatest time
ever to be an artist,
but the supply is greater than ever.
- Yeah.
Cutting through.
- Sure.
But I honestly think that's merit.
Cutting through is
predicated on, are you good?
- Absolutely.
- Are you good at music?
Somebody tweeted, actually
that's fucking crazy.
Somebody just tweeted and I saw it
and I got involved in the tweet.
(reading)
"This is fuckin' bullshit.
"Social media stars are
getting more bigger advances
"than people that have been doing music
"all their lives."
Is that what it is?
That's probably why it happened.
- Who is it with?
- I think he, was it, Atlantic?
- Nonetheless,
audience is audience.
- Yeah.
- There's a consumer, there's someone,
there's an audience, someone
who's gonna pay for it.
- What was that event?
- It has to be a ton, he has fuckin'
the amount of fuckin'
13 to 22 year old girls
that are obsessed with
him are through the roof!
They buy a fuckin' lot of music.
If you're a label, you're like,
alright, let me get this straight.
An enormous amount of 12 to 25 year olds
think you're the best?
How do you think that's gonna play out?
That was weird.
- Yeah, the only downfall
with that is that
they tried to do that with them
putting them on screen
and it doesn't translate.
- It doesn't translate until it does,
to your point.
Airplane's a shitty movie.
The Kardashians is
bullshit, until it's not!
- Yeah.
- You're in the Hollywood world,
I went there a lot during this time.
Netflix got shit on by Hollywood!
- Completely.
- Shit on!
I'd be at CAA, hearing people
I would bring it up, I'm like,
I really like what Netflix
they're like, get the
Netflix made PBS feel like HBO.
It was like
to me, that's what's great.
Our guy, Tee Grizzley.
It's great that if his song,
4 Days After Jail is fire,
then his career starts.
There's plenty of people,
so to me, the audience is the only one.
And all of our fuckin'
opinions and fuckin'
all the media outlets and all the managers
and all the agents and
all the publications
and meme accounts.
It's just the audience.
- Yeah.
- There's nothing else,
and to me, penetrating them,
and giving yourself an at bat,
and then really trying to figure out
how to bring value to
A, the audience, always,
but you do that by nature in trying to
produce a piece of art that people enjoy.
And then, B, trying to find
leverage with the distributor.
Whoever's distributing that music.
You have the ultimate leverage.
For a certain demo, 27 to 36,
you have fame.
And good fame.
Nostalgic, warm, fuzzy fame.
I just think a lot of
people are going to say yes.
I just, if I were fuckin' on this team
and just sitting down with you guys
and hung out for 60 days,
I'd be like, alright.
Let's try to figure out who we think
watched Nickelodeon, and
is 26 to 34 years old.
Let's go.
Let's DM them all.
- That's the interesting
thing we've been noticing too,
'cause the show, it's like Full House,
so it still airs.
- Yeah, to your point.
- Six year olds, 10
year olds, 13 year olds,
there's no demographic.
But the 27, 28 year olds
will call up a radio
and now the program directors
and now the this and that are
oh, of course, we grew up on that
- It's definitely been helping.
- If you're waking up at dawn,
I'll tell you right now, three to five.
The first thing I would do,
is hire somebody at minimum wage, free
or a low salary, to
literally business develop
on DM, 24 hours a day.
And again, if you're 28
year old Sally or Rick,
and they think you're cool,
I would have done it
for Macho Man for free.
- Oh yeah.
(laughs)
- It's a trade!
D-Rock did it for a little
'cause it was a trade,
he thought I was cool
after he did his homework.
Thought it was worthwhile
and he was right.
- Yeah.
- So, to me,
I actually just think it's grinding.
I think the 2018 version of
doing shows every night at
shitty fuckin' restaurants
and fuckin' pubs and
fuckin' this and that,
which you probably
would have not had to do
to the same shitty level,
given the prior equity that you had.
But like, if you're a comedian today,
you can either go and do open mic, or
you can make content and then DM people
for those same four hours.
I think people underestimate,
I don't think people have understood
the depth of spending four or five hours
trying to connect with
people, and bring them
the problem is, the
people that understand it
are either the most
desperate or the smartest.
The most desperate just spam you.
I don't know I just get spammed
fuckin' 50 thousand times a day.
The smartest win.
And then everybody else
just disregards it.
I just don't think it's disregarding.
- That's literally what we,
that's how I got to you and I just
sit there like, oh this person's cool?
Oh he follows that person?
- I mean that's how
we are making music
- I slide into the DM's
(crosstalk)
- He beat me to it,
and I'm locking us in.
Why?
'Cause you know, love the show.
- We
- The same way, I apologize,
same way when I see a Jets player,
Beyonce can DM me and
if underneath that is
Tom Hennessy the long snapper of the Jets,
I'm like, yo!
Hit up Hennessy.
We'll get to Beyonce in four minutes.
- It's amazing.
- Everybody has what they care about.
- For sure.
- I think you've been doing
that for collaboration purposes.
I think you now have to
start thinking about that
for distribution purposes.
- Yeah, we've definitely been
using it for collaboration
and just branding deals to bring in
- Makes sense.
Hustling, I love that.
But I would say
- This is a whole 'nother level.
- Go look at all the pop, pop culture,
music, pop, '90s nostalgia
I would go to every fuckin',
I would go to every Nickelodeon meme page
and DM, be like, yo, it's me!
(laughs)
Would mean a lot to me if you fuckin',
played this one minute clip of my song.
You know who you should look up?
Tierra Whack.
You seen what's going on with her?
She's really interesting, she's an artist
that we really kinda got into.
She just dropped a project and it's going
super viral.
Her name's Tierra Whack.
T
- I-e-r-r-a
- What she did was super smart.
She dropped an album, 15 songs,
all one minute songs
so that the whole song would fit into
an Instagram video.
(pop music)
And then she's gonna watch
how everybody reacts,
and make full versions of
the songs that really popped.
- No way.
- Clever.
- That's very clever.
- So she did crowd feedback.
And these are real songs.
- Yeah, yeah this is good.
- And she's very Missy
Elliott, Lauryn Hill,
she's a real talent.
Yeah, and by the way,
it was like 20 thousand two minutes ago.
Everybody's cosigning her.
'Cause she put out this
I mean this is real music.
- Like Lil Dicky
- Yeah.
If you go to Twitter,
if you go to her Twitter,
everybody's like, Meek
Mill's like, "she's next".
She's really hit it.
♪ They took my dog away ♪
♪ They treat him like a stray ♪
- What I think you should consider
is making one minute
videos that are collateral
that you can DM all these people.
They're always looking for content.
- Yeah.
- Absolutely.
- It's a real grind.
I don't think people
realize how I got here.
I fucking spent 14 hours a day on Twitter
from 2007 to 2010.
Like, every day!
- Yeah.
- Everybody thinks it's overnight!
- It's like my dad.
My dad'll come in over to my house
and he's like,
why guys over here done nothing,
I'm like, Dad, you don't understand!
You don't just create an app
and then it just happens on Thursday
- There's like seven Instagrams!
- Years, years and years
of research and development.
- And by the way, even
when it happens overnight
and Snapchat had a very fast path,
there's one of them!
- Yeah.
- You can go win the lotto, too!
- Yeah, exactly.
- Let's go!
200 million, let's go!
Fuckin' America, go fuckin'
scratch off your shit!
It doesn't work that way.
- Yeah.
- Overnight success is you
don't see the 12 years of
- Beyonce fucking shaked her ass from
nine years old on.
Star Search this, fuckin'
her dad was dragging
those fuckin' four girls
everywhere, fuckin' rodeo that.
Fuckin' mall this.
It fuckin' takes work!
To your point, that four and 10am thing,
it's work, I worked 15 hours a day!
I fuckin' was in Helsinki last week,
had a full day in Helsinki,
fuckin' flew to America
and fuckin' started that day!
Oh everyone's like, oh, so lucky.
- Yeah.
- But, you gotta give yourself a chance.
And I think one minute music videos
distributed,
even if it's
I'll tell you something real clever.
I even think one minute,
I would be filming everything.
You and your writing partner or
somebody else, even just a snippet of
the making of a song.
Do you know how happy
you would be right now
if you had the film of the 12 hours where
you made the theme song.
- Oh hell yeah!
- Oh yeah.
- Do you know how cool this is gonna be
when we watch this
exact video in 40 years?
- Yeah.
- It's cool.
So I would be recording more,
and I would be thinking about
Instagram's gonna have
another 24 to 36 months
no matter what happens.
Anything can happen but
our society's attention that we care about
lives there.
Winning there matters.
Period.
And then, listen, if I'm a songwriter,
then I'm gaming it itself.
I was telling one really
big hip hop artist
I was like, the day Roseanne Barr thing,
I'm like, you need to go in the studio
and create a song called Barrs
with two r's hanging out
- Oh yeah!
- And just fuckin' talk
about your point of view
on not necessarily
of course you want to make
one reference to Roseanne,
but it's more about social commentating
on the state of the union.
- Yeah.
- When you're a fuckin'
songwriter, you got power.
There's a fuckin' volcano
in Guatemala right now.
Right?
You could write about it,
if it was authentic.
I saw Kap G must have some family there,
maybe his family
he should be in the studio right now
making a song, donating all the proceeds
to the victims of Guatemala
and call it Volcano and just go.
That could be the biggest hit in all of
South America this whole summer.
You see where I'm goin'?
We Are The World.
I think a lot of times
in like We Are The World.
You know?
- Yep.
- When Nicki Jam just did
that thing with Will Smith
about World Cup, that's smart!
Here comes the World Cup,
it's fuckin' two popular people,
lot of audience.
(claps)
Right?
Of course, and I think they did it
because they had a deal already
but if they didn't,
you could just see
commercials hitting them up.
Hacking culture, both
from a writing standpoint
and a distribution standpoint.
I make videos for 47 year olds and then
run ads on Facebook for people over 47.
I'm gonna say something different than,
I'm not gonna talk about
you're halfway through life
and you've got this,
and maybe you're 15
years into your marriage,
that's not gonna connect for you.
- Yeah.
- But when I fuckin' make a video for
hey kids, you just graduated and
you don't know what the fuck you wanna do
and your parents pressure this,
that's gonna work for a 22 year old.
I think you can be doing more of that
from a writing standpoint.
What I would call social
I think nothing's more interesting than
people's opinions, that's what we love.
Hot takes in sports and fuckin'
people watch
- We get Cardi B, she's the
biggest thing on the planet.
That's what got,
she started just being
real on Instagram and
people were like,
oh shit.
- Authenticity fuckin'
plays, man.
- Yeah.
Just being honest.
- Hundred percent.
Right?
Especially in the times,
I pay enough attention
to culture it seemed
you and this Josh dude,
you guys had something.
It was in the news, right?
At some point, a year ago,
weddings and stuff
- Yeah yeah yeah.
- That's like an interesting time to
write the truth.
Your truth.
Not like whatever the back and forth was
or the stuff you would feel comfortable.
Maybe just feelings.
I don't know.
I like sharing feelings.
- Could you imagine if he wrote a song
about your feelings about Josh?
(laughs)
It would be, people would,
that's a good idea.
- People would cry.
- Of course they would cry,
especially if you did it
100 percent based on truth,
not what you think would play.
I will tell you the single biggest reason
I think I win, and I win bigger than
where I am now, long term,
is I never ever waver from my truth.
We have a sports agency now,
and we represent, my brother and I,
and we represent players.
ESPN asks me to do this fluffy interview
for their mobile thing
with one of my players,
four hours before the NFL Draft
we're in Dallas.
Our player, Josh Jackson was going in
the first round, the whole time.
Every draft, first round,
first round, first round.
Literally when we got to Dallas
two days before draft,
we started talking to teams
and I'll never forget it,
one guy just said to us,
you think he'll go into second round?
And we're like, whoa whoa
what are you talking about,
he's going first round!
And he was kind of alluding to
he might slip out of the second round.
And I just remember how it was going,
which I didn't think he
would ever go third round
but I definitely started
putting pieces together
the team started putting pieces together,
AJ and the rest of the team
was feeding me back and
it now became a realistic thing
that he may slip out of the first round.
So we sit down, we're on the couch
and I'm supposed to interview him
and a couple other, Kyle, Allen,
one of our other guys and
a couple of my agents,
we're gonna hang out.
My first question went right at Josh!
This is my own guy!
And I was like, hey man,
so for three, last eight weeks,
you've been told that you're gonna be
a first round pick in the NFL Draft
and here we are hours before the NFL Draft
and there's a significant
chance you may slip out.
And you're about to go into a green room
with a bunch of guys and you might be
the last guy in there, and
you might not get drafted.
Are you ready for that?
And it was funny.
I almost didn't even
understand what the fuck I was
it was almost an out of body
I was like, what am I doing?
Why am I an investigative reporter
on my own guy?
I'm asking a question other news outlets.
No, even other news outlets were like,
nah I'm not gonna fuck with the kid
just because the truth
is always gonna win.
I did it in the wine business
when I started that wine show.
I panned wines of friends.
Like, friends.
Friends, friends, friends.
People that let me sleep on their couch
when I went to Napa and here I am
at the height of my popularity in 2012.
Hundreds of thousands of
people watching my show.
Me driving wine sales in America.
Wine moved because of what I said,
and I'm like this wine,
moved both ways.
And I'm sitting there,
and I just knew that
I had to tell the truth.
It's like when I go on the Breakfast Club.
It's really tough to go on Breakfast Club
when you're a 42 year old white man
and be like, nobody cares
about your problems.
That's dangerous territory,
I'm not tone deaf, I
just know it's the truth.
And I just think the truth will help.
It will always win.
So, back to that song,
yes, if you actually were
100 percent authentic,
not 99.
- That's the only way.
- You can't win when you're
leaving something on the field.
Anyway, so I would think
a lot about culture
from a writing standpoint.
Think about this.
Something can happen in culture,
whatever it is.
Volcano in Guatemala, Roseanne Barr,
something positive.
I know we're filming this
but fuck it, I'll say it for the purpose.
Audience, you know I
don't like to go here.
Some little girl gave
her shoes or something
to another girl.
Remember about the thousand
dollar gift certificate
to Amazon?
A couple weeks ago, some little girl
went viral 'cause she got a gift card
and what she did with it.
- Someone in the class
wanted her shoes
was sad, his family couldn't afford it.
For his birthday, she came
in and gave him the shoes.
- But I think on her birthday,
it was just a great story.
Where she did right by somebody
and gave up her shoes to somebody else.
I sent her $1,000 Zappos gift card
I was like, buy as many
fuckin' shoes as you want.
Right?
- Yeah.
- That's my
I don't talk a lot about the stuff I do
like that, even this was
a little bit uncomfortable
but I want the audience to hear it
because, you could have
wrote a song about that,
that could have been like Gifting Shoes.
And then you could have taken it,
it would have just been in the zeitgeist.
You might have made one little reference
by rhyming her name
and she would have thought
that's the coolest,
but the bigger thing was selflessness
and how doing the right thing is
always the right thing.
- Mmhmm.
- And, you could have it out the next day.
Got it?
- Yeah.
- The reason nobody
used to write like that
is 'cause the album came
out nine months later
and that moment was gone.
- Completely.
- With the way we're doing things,
if it's just
- See where I'm going?
- Or even if it's a one minute clip,
you don't even have to record the song,
you can just do it live, know what I mean?
- Or you just fuckin' record the song.
And if Soundcloud's your minor leagues,
if Spotify's your major leagues,
you can play!
You could.
I don't think people take enough risks
'cause they're precious with their music.
I think no one song can kill you,
I think one song can make you huge
for the rest of your life.
And that's how my brain works.
- Yeah.
- And I think artists think
one song can kill them.
- Totally.
- And I think they're wrong.
Lil Wayne put out an entire fuckin' album
where he's like fuckin' Jimi Hendrix.
- Or Snoop, the whole Rastafarian
- Yeah, Snoop Dogg, Snoop Lion.
Everybody's put out a bullshit song.
(laughs)
We make unlimited videos that suck shit.
Especially when D-Rock edits.
(laughs)
Oh shit, okay, cool.
Nine minutes ago?
- Yeah I mean he was
- Okay.
Yeah I mean feel free to use this
as like a springpad to a relationship
and you just hit me up cold,
we'll help.
- Awesome.
- Just tell me what matters.
We'll definitely use some
music in our content.
- Oh great, yeah.
- You'll text me his contact card?
- Yeah yeah and that's also
if there can just be an
open line of dialogue
- That's it.
Yeah, that's always what I
want out of these things too.
- Everything that I hear you say,
it's literally, some of the stuff is
like, babe, remember three weeks ago
- I was sayin'
I get it.
- That what I was
if you live for Friday
(laughs)
Our biggest thing is,
I can't stand people, they're
not working on weekends,
okay so we have to wait 'til Monday
to get an answer?
- Oh it drives me nuts.
- Our weekend is
- Or, or, or literally,
the amount of people today
that are already looking at the weather
on Saturday and Sunday.
- Yeah.
- Already looking at
their Friday afternoon,
which is great, and listen,
you know what's funny?
I now do it more than ever,
because I'm enjoying my
weekends with my family
so much.
So I get it,
the bigger theme is if you hate
your Monday through Friday,
you're in big trouble.
You in big fuckin' trouble.
How do people not understand that
when you eliminate sleeping,
it is what you do.
You will be 20 to 70,
20 to 59,
you will spend your prime of your life
more than 50 percent of it in a job.
I mean you better really
fuckin' think about it.
- [Janet] Yeah yeah yeah.
- [Drake] If you're miserable in them
- And then people have jobs they hate
just to maintain their lifestyles,
which is completely usually based on
other people's opinions.
So much broken, there's
so much opportunity.
- [Drake] Keeping up with the Joneses
- Keeping up with the Joneses
that would be one of the
first songs on my album.
- [Janet] Instagram.
- A hundred percent.
Instagram amplifies it.
But it's fashion, too.
It's what we do, it's
how we express ourselves.
- Absolutely.
- Keeping up with the Joneses.
That would literally be one of my
I would probably call it something like
Keeping up with the Vaynerchuks and
write a song and be like,
you fuckers!
Please do not care.
Why, do you know how wrong?
Everything is wrong when you care about
somebody else's
people buy homes and
neighborhoods they can't afford,
'cause they're gonna
- Drive cars they can't afford.
- It's like you were saying,
who utilizes their six bedrooms?
- I'm hot on that now.
Right?
- Get
- You get
- Awesome.
- Thank you so much.
- Enjoy New York, of course, guys.
♪ Can't rewind ♪
♪ Don't waste your time ♪
♪ And we'll find ♪
♪ That we're intertwined ♪